well it's to myanmar now where
protesters are
out on the streets again to continue
their demonstrations against
last month's military coup tens of
thousands are marching with the largest
protests in the city of mandalay
there are protests too in the largest
city yangon it follows police raids
targeting opposition leaders witnesses
described hearing shots during those
raids
a number of people were arrested it
comes as the chinese government says
it's willing to work with the relevant
parties
to ease tensions
close to the ground for safety her shirt
says
everything will be okay but it wasn't
for mandalay university student kyal sin
she was shot in the head and killed as
police opened fire on protesters last
wednesday
thousands attended her funeral a day
later giving the three-finger salute
it's become a gesture of solidarity
among pro-democracy civilians
and a show of defiance against the
military
kielsen hasn't been allowed to rest in
peace
witnesses say her grave was disturbed by
soldiers
shortly after her burial
they allege her body was subject to a
graveside autopsy by military doctors
only adding to the outrage over her
killing
kyal sin's story is no isolated incident
wednesday was the deadliest day since
protests began at the start of february
but u.n figures show more than 50
civilian protesters have been killed
since the military coup many people say
the international community
isn't doing enough
like this nun who took to the streets to
stand between vulnerable protesters
and the riot police
there's no one to protect myanmar's
people
people have to defend themselves and
help each other as we can't trust anyone
it's not safe they arrest and beat those
they don't like and kill them
diplomatic efforts so far have failed
the un's special envoy has urged the
security council to act now
but it hasn't stopped one day of
violence many are wondering when
everything will really be okay on the
streets of myanmar again
journalist amin tant joins me now from
yangon
a police have stepped up raids overnight
have we seen much violence there today
uh yes although we haven't seen quite as
much violence as we saw earlier in the
week and on last sunday
there has been quite a lot more violence
than we saw in the last few days
during the night rates quite a number of
people reported seeing their neighbors
being taken
who were then subsequently beaten and in
fact we saw that one
local national league for democracy ward
official
was actually killed due to his injuries
sustained while they were being raided
and then uh regarding protests that
happened throughout the day we also saw
that police were stepping up
some of their crown dispersal methods
from the last few days which was largely
through stun grenades as well as
uh smoke tear gas today we saw that
police began to use rubber bullets as
well as live bullets again
right now the chinese government we're
hearing is saying that they're willing
to engage with all sides and all parties
to ease tensions
in myanmar what's their role in this
so the chinese government has a very
long history in myanmar
being myanmar's neighbor in terms of
sharing a land border as well as being
one of the largest economies
in the region the chinese government has
also had
a hand in the development of the country
through foreign direct investment as
well as
in the ongoing conflicts especially in
the border regions with ethnic
minorities
at times arming ethnic armed
organizations as well as
arming and supplying and supporting the
myanmar military
and so it's it's a very complicated sort
of relationship
and many in the pro-democratic camp are
definitely very suspicious of chinese
involvement
all right amen journalist in yangon
thanks very much for the update
thank you for having me